hello comrade
stan so animal farm
by uh george orwell is uh one of my
favorite books
it's an allegory about at least i think
about the soviet union
and the russian revolution of 1917
so for people who haven't read it it's
uh animals
overthrow the humans and then slowly
become as bad or
worse than the humans so comrade
if we lived on this farm in the book
animal farm
which animal would you most rather be
would it be the pigs the horses
the donkey benjamin the raven moses the
humans mr mrs jones the dogs or the
sheep
um i'm gonna go with the milton answer
which is better to rule in hell than
serve in heaven
right it's better to rule in health and
serve in heaven yeah so i would have to
go with
the pigs so i guess i'd be a cop um
at the very top so the leader the main
pig napoleon versus like the wallet or
the other
yeah i i would say it's not it's sure
it's an allegory but the russian
revolution but i think
um orwell's point was this is broader
towards most totalitarian dictatorships
i mean
it could very easily be read as an
indictment of mussolini or hitler
or many of these others uh i'm a huge um
george orwell fan one of the things that
i think people on the right
need to appreciate is the courage
of many of these in undisputably
left-wing voices who were the strongest
ones to take on
uh totalitarianism totalitarian
communism and the three i think off top
my head who are all
in my top ten heroes of all time are
emma goldman
uh albert camus uh and orwell being the
third
you know something that uh leftists like
to throw in the face
of people on the right who constantly
invoke orwell is that orwell said and i
don't have the exact quote on top of my
head but some to the effect of
every word i have written is in should
be taken as a defense of democratic
socialism against totalitarianism
so uh people like truman you know was
obviously very hardcore
in many ways anti-communist uh we like
to parse things out you're gonna laugh
uh into binary fashions that you know
left good right bad or right good left
bad
but historically speaking it was this
not fall away into these camps
as easily as people would like and i
think
it is important for those of us it takes
a lot more courage
to fight the right from the right or to
fight the left from the left
because in a sense a lot of your
countrymen or your fellow travelers are
going to regard you as a traitor to the
cause
so i i every chance i get i will sing
the praises of these three
figures among others who not only even
if they hadn't
done what they had done just lived just
amazing lives that all of us can
uh learn from and admire and
regard as somewhat a role model so
you